Misurare una sovrapposizione quantistica è casuale come lanciare una moneta, ma fino a dove possiamo spingere questa
analogia prima che si rompa? Lo scopriremo oggi su Qiskit in the
Classroom. Benvenuto a Qiskit in the Classroom, una serie di video in cui analizziamo un concetto fondamentale che potresti
incontrare in un corso legato al calcolo quantistico. Ogni video è accompagnato da un modulo interattivo collegato nella
descrizione qui sotto, quindi assicurati di darci un'occhiata. Oggi parliamo di uno dei principi fondamentali al cuore della
teoria quantistica: la sovrapposizione. Nella nostra esperienza quotidiana, gli oggetti hanno sempre caratteristiche definite: la loro posizione, dimensione,
forma, colore — tutto ciò che li riguarda è determinato e certo, anche se noi come osservatori non lo abbiamo ancora misurato. Nel
mondo quantistico, questo non è necessariamente il caso. Un oggetto quantistico può trovarsi in qualcosa chiamato sovrapposizione di
molteplici stati classicamente consentiti, che quando viene misurato collasserà casualmente in uno di quegli
stati. Misurare uno stato di sovrapposizione è come lanciare una moneta: non c'è modo di sapere in anticipo da che parte cadrà.
Questo indeterminismo fondamentale è un aspetto scomodo della meccanica quantistica con cui persino Einstein aveva difficoltà.
Ha detto famosamente "Dio non gioca a dadi" a proposito di questa casualità, ma come vedremo, Dio in effetti gioca a dadi, o nel
nostro caso lancia monete. Ma c'è di più: queste monete sono truccate. Misurare una sovrapposizione quantistica può essere simile al
lancio di una moneta in certi aspetti, ma la sovrapposizione stessa è molto più ricca e complessa di uno stato
probabilistico classico. Per capirlo, penseremo a come funziona una moneta classica e la confronteremo con la nostra
moneta quantistica che esploreremo usando Qiskit su un computer quantistico IBM. Prima di tutto, una moneta classica. È
piuttosto semplice: lanci la moneta e cade o testa o croce con il 50% di probabilità ciascuno. In linea di principio, potremmo
calcolare su quale lato cadrà la moneta se conoscessimo le precise condizioni iniziali e esattamente quanto
forza e coppia vengono applicati durante il lancio. Ma in pratica non c'è modo di sapere a priori su quale lato
cadrà la moneta. Ecco perché usiamo il lancio della moneta come esempio canonico di stato probabilistico classico, in cui il
risultato è essenzialmente casuale. Se dovessi lanciare questa moneta mille volte e registrare il numero di teste e
croci, otterrei un istogramma simile a questo. Quindi abbiamo i conteggi sull'asse Y
e può essere testa o croce, e l'
istogramma mostrerebbe che ci sono circa 500 conteggi di ciascuno, a meno di qualche
fluttuazione statistica. Possiamo creare uno stato simile usando un qubit sul nostro computer quantistico. Come il lancio della moneta, anche un
qubit può essere misurato in due possibili stati: zero e uno. Se applichiamo qualcosa chiamato gate Hadamard al
qubit, lo metterà in un'uguale sovrapposizione di zero e uno. Ecco una
visualizzazione di quel circuit, che chiamiamo diagramma del circuit. Qui il filo in alto è il
qubit e le operazioni applicate al qubit appaiono come caselle sui fili. Il gate Hadamard è mostrato con questa casella
etichettata H e la misurazione è mostrata con questa casella grigia etichettata con il piccolo simbolo di misurazione. Invia quella
misurazione a un bit classico, questo filo con due linee. Quindi, poiché il qubit si trova in un'uguale sovrapposizione di 0 e uno, quando
lo misuriamo ci sarà il 50% di probabilità di misurare zero e il 50% di misurare
uno. Esprimiamo questo stato di sovrapposizione quantistica come s = 1/
√2 |0⟩ + 1/√2 |1⟩, dove i quadrati di ciascuno di questi
coefficienti, chiamati anche ampiezze, sono le probabilità di misurare ogni stato. Quindi, in effetti, applicare il gate Hadamard
è l'analogo del lancio di una moneta. E proprio come abbiamo lanciato la moneta mille volte per guardare la
statistica della moneta che cade testa o croce, possiamo fare qualcosa di simile su Qiskit con la nostra moneta quantistica.
Useremo un primitivo di Qiskit chiamato sampler che ripeterà il circuit più volte per campionare la statistica
dello stato risultante. Con mille campioni del circuit precedente, abbiamo qualcosa che sembra fondamentalmente identico
all'istogramma della moneta classica, a meno di qualche fluttuazione statistica. Quindi è tutto? Le sovrapposizioni quantistiche
sono essenzialmente le stesse di uno stato probabilistico classico, simile al lancio di una moneta? Non proprio. Questo sarebbe
un video piuttosto breve se fosse così. Per vedere la nostra prima differenza fondamentale, proverò qualcosa di leggermente diverso con la mia moneta classica. Invece
di lasciarla semplicemente cadere sul tavolo atterrando testa o croce, lancerò la moneta e la prenderò al volo
tra i miei palmi. Ora la moneta non è né testa né croce, ma è invece testa sinistra
o destra. Quindi la logica ci dice che anche questo dovrebbe avere una probabilità 50/50 di essere
testa sinistra o destra. Per misurare testa sinistra o destra sulla nostra moneta quantistica, possiamo fare ciò che abbiamo fatto con la moneta classica:
misurare lungo un asse diverso. Le nostre misurazioni standard sul computer quantistico sono lungo l'asse verticale,
proprio come la solita misurazione testa o croce della moneta classica. Ma possiamo anche chiedere alla nostra moneta quantistica se è
testa sinistra o destra. Chiamiamo questi due stati lungo l'asse X: più o meno.
Per questo usiamo il primitivo di Qiskit chiamato estimator. Per complicare un po' le cose, invece di restituire un istogramma come
fa il sampler, l'estimator ci darà il cosiddetto valore di aspettazione di qualsiasi osservabile del qubit. Per
capire questo valore di aspettazione, diciamo che guadagni un dollaro ogni volta che la moneta cade testa e perdi un dollaro quando cade
croce. Il valore di aspettazione è quanto denaro puoi aspettarti di guadagnare in media con ogni lancio di moneta. Poiché
hai la stessa probabilità di guadagnare o perdere un dollaro, il valore di aspettazione sarebbe zero. Lo stesso ragionamento può essere applicato
al qubit. Quando troviamo il valore di aspettazione di X, quando applichiamo X allo stato più otteniamo
il valore +1, e allo stato meno otteniamo meno uno. Quindi se avessimo una
distribuzione 50/50 otterremmo un valore di aspettazione di zero. Ma non è così: otteniamo un valore di aspettazione di più uno,
il che significa che la moneta viene sempre misurata come più lungo l'asse X. Sarebbe come lanciare una
moneta, prenderla al volo e garantire che la testa sia sempre rivolta a destra. Questo perché una
sovrapposizione non è solo una distribuzione di probabilità. Ricorda come esprimiamo uno stato quantistico:
s è uguale a c0 moltiplicato per lo stato 0 più c1
moltiplicato per lo stato 1, dove ciascuno di questi coefficienti è complesso, il che significa che
hanno sia parti reali che immaginarie. Quindi ci dicono le probabilità, ma nascondono anche un'altra quantità chiamata
fase. Un certo coefficiente c può essere scritto così,
dove c è uguale alla magnitudine moltiplicata per questa fase, dove φ è la
fase. È un po' come la fase di un'onda, o la posizione delle creste e dei ventri di un'onda. Se due onde sono in fase
tra loro, in modo che le loro creste e i loro ventri si allineino, si combineranno per formare un'onda il doppio più
alta. Chiamiamo questo interferenza costruttiva. Se sono fuori fase come
in questo caso, si interferiscono in modo distruttivo, annullandosi completamente. Per vedere come la fase può causare
interferenza nella nostra moneta quantistica, proviamo ad applicare il gate Hadamard due volte invece di una. Ora classicamente
questo non avrebbe senso: se applicare il gate Hadamard equivale a lanciare una moneta, non puoi lanciare una moneta che sta già girando. Ma vediamo cosa
succede quantisticamente. Quindi applichiamo il gate Hadamard due volte e campionniamo lo stato risultante.
Sorprendentemente, non abbiamo più una probabilità 50/50. L'istogramma risultante mostra che in ogni caso misuriamo il
qubit nello stato zero. Quindi il secondo gate Hadamard ha riportato il qubit allo stato zero da cui era partito. È
un po' difficile da vedere all'inizio, ma questo è grazie all'interferenza dello stato quantistico. Piuttosto che
interferire nello spazio reale come un'onda vera, l'interferenza avviene nello spazio astratto dell'informazione del qubit.
Il secondo gate Hadamard ha fatto sì che la parte zero della sovrapposizione interferisse costruttivamente, mentre la parte uno della
sovrapposizione ha interferito distruttivamente ed è scomparsa. Esploriamo ulteriormente. Possiamo cambiare la fase usando
qualcosa chiamato gate di fase. Quindi ora proviamo ad applicare un gate Hadamard per creare la sovrapposizione, applicare uno sfasamento di
π radianti e poi applicare il secondo gate Hadamard. Ora sembra che la nostra moneta quantistica esca sempre nello stato uno.
Lo sfasamento di π ha scambiato le parti dello stato di sovrapposizione che erano in fase e fuori fase tra loro,
quindi lo stato finale è uno invece di zero. Sarebbe come lanciare una moneta e mentre è in aria essere in grado di
applicare un'operazione che garantirebbe che atterrasse sempre testa o sempre croce a seconda dell'operazione.
Impossibile nel caso classico, ma non in quello quantistico. Quello che abbiamo imparato da questi esperimenti è
che questa nuova capacità della moneta quantistica è dovuta alla sua fase, una qualità che una sovrapposizione quantistica ha ma che una
distribuzione di probabilità classica non ha. Quindi il solito lancio della moneta non è davvero una buona analogia per una
sovrapposizione, perché non dice nulla di questa fase. Penso che possiamo fare di meglio. Farò un altro
esperimento con la nostra moneta. Ho la moneta posata sul tavolo con la testa rivolta verso l'alto. Per renderla croce, posso semplicemente girarla. Questo
è l'equivalente computazionale di un gate NOT. Diciamo che vogliamo costruire un'operazione che se applicata due volte sia
equivalente a questo gate NOT. Possiamo chiamare questa operazione la radice quadrata del NOT. Quindi pensa a cosa stiamo facendo fisicamente
quando applichiamo il gate NOT: la stiamo ruotando di 180° attorno, ad esempio, all'asse X. Quindi se ruotassimo la moneta
di soli 90° attorno all'asse X, otterremmo la radice quadrata del NOT. Quindi abbiamo applicato
la nostra radice quadrata del NOT e la moneta è semplicemente in equilibrio sul suo bordo. Ora possiamo chiederci: è testa o croce? Beh,
chiaramente non è nessuna delle due. Ma potremmo aggiungere un passaggio al processo di misurazione per costringerla ad essere testa o croce. Ora la
moneta cadrà sul lato testa o croce con uguale probabilità. Di nuovo, in linea di principio potremmo prevedere
da che parte cadrà, ma in pratica è abbastanza difficile da prevedere da rendere il risultato essenzialmente casuale. Se voglio
misurare se è testa sinistra o destra, posso schiacciarla in quella direzione in modo simile, e ci darà di nuovo una
probabilità 50/50 di sinistra e destra. Ma in questa dimensione — testa davanti o dietro —
la testa è già rivolta in avanti, quindi il 100% delle volte la misureremo testa davanti. Quindi, mentre le misurazioni lungo X e Z
davano risultati casuali, la misurazione lungo Y darà sempre lo stesso risultato. Se pensiamo all'esperimento della moneta quantistica
della sezione precedente, questo ricorda come si comportava la moneta quantistica dopo aver applicato il gate Hadamard: il qubit veniva misurato
come zero o 1 con probabilità 50/50 nella direzione Z, ma sempre nello stato più
e mai nello stato meno lungo X. Questo suggerisce che forse una moneta in equilibrio sul bordo è un modo migliore
per visualizzare uno stato di sovrapposizione di un qubit rispetto a una moneta che gira freneticamente nell'aria.
Applichiamo un gate radice quadrata del NOT alla nostra moneta quantistica in Qiskit. Abbiamo questo semplice
circuit. Poi useremo l'estimator per verificare il valore di aspettazione delle tre osservabili X, Y e Z, che sono un po' come
far collassare la nostra moneta lungo ciascuna delle tre dimensioni come ho appena mostrato. Quindi i valori di aspettazione sono 0,
meno uno e 0 per X, Y e Z rispettivamente. Questo è lo stesso risultato che
abbiamo ottenuto per la rotazione della radice quadrata del NOT applicata alla moneta classica. In effetti c'è un'analogia precisa tra la
moneta e lo stato del qubit. Ora possiamo visualizzare lo stato del qubit come un vettore che punta nella direzione della testa
sulla moneta, normale alla superficie della moneta. Quindi testa in su, ovvero lo stato zero,
sulla moneta quantistica equivale a un vettore che punta dritto verso l'alto. Testa in giù, ovvero uno, punta dritto verso il basso, e qualsiasi
uguale sovrapposizione di 0 e uno punta orizzontalmente. La fase dello stato quantistico determina la precisa direzione orizzontale
verso cui punta — per esempio, se punta lungo l'asse X o lungo l'asse Y o in qualche posto
nel mezzo. Questo vettore è noto come vettore di Bloch e determina completamente e univocamente lo stato quantistico di un singolo
qubit. Possiamo ora reimmaginare ogni gate che abbiamo visto in questo video come una rotazione o una serie di rotazioni sulla
moneta, o in modo equivalente sul vettore di Bloch. Il gate NOT è una rotazione di
180° attorno all'asse X. Quando applicato al nostro stato zero, ovvero testa in su, porta allo stato
giù, ovvero uno. La radice quadrata del NOT è solo 90° attorno allo stesso asse X. Partendo dallo
stato testa in su, questo lo ruota fino a testa davanti. Un gate di fase è una rotazione di φ attorno all'asse Z. Poiché
testa in su è allineata con l'asse Z, questo non fa niente alla moneta. Il gate Hadamard è un po' più complicato: lo avevamo
inizialmente paragonato al lancio di una moneta, facendo girare la moneta in modo incontrollabile nell'aria, ma il gate Hadamard è in realtà una
rotazione controllata e deterministica della moneta, come tutti gli altri gate. Il gate Hadamard viene eseguito ruotando di 90°
attorno all'asse Y e poi di 180° attorno all'asse X. Quindi applicato allo stato testa in su porta
allo stato testa destra. Quindi non c'è nulla di casuale in uno stato di sovrapposizione quantistica o in nessuna delle
operazioni standard che eseguiamo sul qubit. Ogni operazione è deterministica e reversibile. L'unica
volta in cui la casualità entra in gioco è quando decidiamo di misurare lo stato quantistico. Se uno stato quantistico sia o meno in una
sovrapposizione dipende davvero da chi guarda. Come avrai probabilmente già incontrato, siamo liberi di scegliere il nostro
sistema di coordinate: X, Y e Z possono puntare lungo qualsiasi tre direzioni ortogonali. Quindi
se abbiamo una sovrapposizione di 0 e uno in un sistema di coordinate, possiamo definire un nuovo sistema di coordinate, o una nuova cosiddetta
base, in cui lo stato punta puramente nella direzione Z positiva e quindi non si trova in uno stato di sovrapposizione.
Quindi quando diciamo che un qubit è in sovrapposizione, dobbiamo anche definire il nostro sistema di coordinate o
base. Potresti uscire da questo modulo con l'impressione di aver appena rimosso tutto il mistero dalla meccanica quantistica.
Dopotutto, uno degli aspetti presumibilmente più strani — lo stato di sovrapposizione di un qubit — è davvero semplice come un
vettore tridimensionale. Ma tieni presente che la moneta è ancora solo un'analogia e anche il vettore di Bloch è
solo uno strumento di visualizzazione. Per calcolare le probabilità dei risultati delle misurazioni, non possiamo dire cosa stia
facendo davvero uno stato quantistico prima di misurarlo, perché verificarlo richiede una misurazione. Discuteremo questo
dilemma — qual è la vera natura di uno stato quantistico e come il fenomeno quantistico dell'entanglement può aiutarci a
chiarire questo — in un altro episodio di Qiskit in the Classroom, tutto sulla disuguaglianza di Bell. Nel frattempo però, se
vuoi giocare con le monete quantistiche per imparare da solo riguardo agli stati di sovrapposizione di un qubit e come controllarli,
vai al modulo delle monete quantistiche collegato nella descrizione. Grazie per aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta.